صدق الكنيست الاسرائيلي بالقراءتين
الثانيه والثالثه على الغاء بنود في قانون
الانفصالي الانفصال الاحادي الجانب عن
قطاع غزه واربع مستوطنات شمال الضفه
الغربيه وذلك بعد 18 عاما من اقراره ويهدف
التعديل الذي اصبح نافدا الى الغاء بنود
كانت تحضر على المستوطنين دخولا نطاق اربع
مستوطنات تم اخلائها في الضفه الغربيه عام
2005 على نحو يتيح اعاده توطينها من جديد
وكان الغاء بنود هذا القانون جزء من
الشروط التي وضعتها احزاب اليمين المتطرف
لقاء الانضمام الى توليفه بنيامين نتنياهو
الحكوميه
هذا وقال رئيس لجنه الخارجيه والامن في
الكنيست الاسرائيليه يولي ادلجتين ان
التصديق على الغاء قانون الانفصال سيعزز
من الاستيطان ويساعد في محاربه اسرائيل
للارهاب وفق تعبيره
لقد صدقنا على الغاء قانون الانفصال هؤلاء
الناس الرائعون سيعودون لارضهم والى ارض
عائلاتهم ولن يعدوا بعد الان مخالفين
للقانون نتطلع لاعاده بناء المستوطنات
وهذا سيساعدنا ليس في الاستيطان فحسب انما
في محاربتنا للارهاب وتطوير ارض اسرائيل
اننا بفضل ايمان هؤلاء الناس الموجودين
معنا سنحقق ذلك
معنى الان من امام الكنيسه الاسرائيلي في
القدس الغربيه مراسله الجزيره ليساسكا
رامي الياس ماذا ما هو هذا القانون وماذا
يعني التصديق على الغائه قانون الانفصاليه
اولا ازدهار بنيامين التنياهو رفع يده
مؤيدا لقانون الانفصال احادي الجانب عن
غزه واربع مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله عندما احضر الى الكنيست في عام
2005 للتصديق عليه وتم تنفيذه فيما بعد
بنياميناهو كان طيله هذه السنوات ملاما
على انه ايد هذا الانفصال تحديدا من
شركائه في اليمين الاسرائيلي واليوم وهو
على راس حكومته السادسه وكانه يصحح غبنا
او خطا تاريخيا كما يوصف على الاقل في
اوساط اعضاء اليمين الاسرائيلي تحديدا في
احزاب اقصى اليمين المتطرف وكانهم يصححون
ويعدلون غمنا تاريخيا او خطا تاريخيا
ارتكب في الماضي ومن الواضح بان الغاء هذا
القانون اليوم كان جزءا من الاتفاق
الائتلافي بين احزاب اقصى اليمين وبين
حكومه وبين حزب الكود الذي مكن بنيامين او
عمليا من اقامه وتشكيل في الحكومه كان هذا
احد الشروط من شروط كثيره وضعها عربون
الاستيطان في حكومه بني نتنياهو من اجل
الانضمام الى تولفته وكان على ان ينفذ هذه
الشروط وهذه البنود اذا كان يريد ان يحافظ
على بقائه على راس السلطه
وينعم باستقرار توليفته الحاكمه وبالتالي
كان التصديق على الغاء هذا القانون سريعا
للغايه في ظرف اسبوعين جرت جراء التصويت
عليه بالقراءه الاولى ثم جرت هنالك بعض
المناقشات السريعه داخل لجان الكنيست
المختصه وهذا اليوم صباحا تم التصديق
النهائي عليه بالقراءتين الثانيه والثالثه
والهدف الاساسي منه الان هو اعاده توطين
اربع مستوطنات تم اخلائها في اطار هذا
القانون الذي شرع في عام 2005 لتنفيذ
الانفصال عن قطاع غزه وهذه المستوطنات
الهدف الاساسي هو تبييض كنيس دي اقيم في
مستوطنه حومش تحديدا وهنالك التماس الى
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه الذي يجبر
هؤلاء المستوطنين على الانسحاب او على
اخلاء هذا الكنيس والخروج من المستوطنه
لكن الان بعد هذا التعديل القانوني وكان
الحكومه تبيض صفحه المستوطنين ويصبح
دخولهم الى هذه المستوطنات شرعيه وغير
مخالف للقانون ليس اكيدا بان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ستعمل سريعا على اعاده توطين
هذه المستوطنات لان هذا الامر قد يصطدم
بطبيعه الحال بمعارضه فلسطينيه جارفه
وكذلك ضغوط اوروبيه وامريكيه من جانب
اصدقائي اسرائيل حول العالم الذين ربما
سيطالبونها بعدم تنفيذ هذا التعديل وعدم
اعاده توطين هذه المستوطنات لكن من ناحيه
اخرى هنالك فرح كبير وغبطه كبيره في اوساط
قاده المستوطنين والمستوطنين انفسهم على
ان هذا التعديل يصحح غبنا وخطا تاريخيا
نظرهم ويعيدهم الى بناء هذه المستوطنات
وتوطينها يبقى ايضا بطبيعه الحال الجانب
العسكري في هذا السياق بمعنى ان التصديق
من جانب الكنيسه الاسرائيلي ومن جانب
المستوى السياسي ربما يكونوا مرهونا ايضا
بموافقه وزير الدفاع على ذلك بصفته
المسؤول ايضا عن
اداره الشؤون العسكريه والمدنيه في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي ربما يضع ايضا في اعتبارات اعاده
توطين هذه المستوطنات المسائل والنواحي
القانونيه المترتبه على ذلك لا سيما وان
الامر والوضع مشتعل ميدنيا في كافه ارجاء
الضفه الغربيه المحتله شكرا جزيلا لك من
امام الكنيست الاسرائيلي في القدس الغربيه